[Musica]
[Applauso]
da cannes a isola rizza land of the week
tipo one touch roc nation eder expenses
[Musica]
camouflage cesena
il gas
[Applauso]
ciao
ciao a tutti io sono fabio zaffagnini e
sono l'ideatore di questa follia che
avete appena guardato vi capita
abbastanza spesso di andare in giro a
raccontare a parlare di sogni dopo dopo
questa avventura di rocchi mille e se
devo dire la verità da quel giorno ogni
giorno su facebook la mia la mia bacheca
è piena di questi messaggi spi razionali
del tipo se vuoi farlo ci devi provare
stay hungry stay foolish
se insomma vai spara alto così però la
domanda è esiste un modo davvero è
ragionevole e razionale per inseguire i
sogni e quello di cui voglio parlare è
esattamente di questo vorrei parlare del
processo di inseguimento dei sogni
non posso farlo senza partire dalla mia
storia personale io sono sempre stato un
grandissimo sognatore fin da bambino per
diventare indiana jones
voglio diventare un campione di beach
volley volevo girare tutto il mondo
sulle navi oceanografiche volevo
inventare il nuovo google street view
ovviamente tutto questo è finito in un
meraviglioso buco nell'acqua nel 2014
invece ho cominciato a sognare da di
vedere un concerto della mia band
preferita i foo fighters nella mia città
che è quella di cesena
ovvio che una band così grande non
sarebbe mai andato in una città così
piccola senza organizzare qualcosa di
speciale quindi insieme a un gruppo di
amici abbiamo messo in piedi il progetto
di rocky 1000 mille musicisti avrebbero
dovuto suonare tutti insieme
contemporaneamente una loro canzone
avremmo fatto questo video avranno fatto
questo appello e poi incrociando le dita
dave grohl e compagni si sarebbero
convinti ora è ovvio che adesso la
faccia abbastanza breve però se abbiamo
lavorato per un anno come dei pazzi per
trovare i soldi per trovare i musicisti
per capire il modo di farli di farli
suonare e il 24 luglio il 2015 mille
musicisti provenienti da tutta italia
sono avvenuti nella città di cesena
hanno suonato meravigliosamente è
risultato è quello che avete che avete
visto nel video che mi ha preceduto
ora il mio diventato virale oggi conta
più di 40 milioni di visualizzazioni foo
fighters hanno visto questo questo video
ci hanno risposto sono venuti a cesena a
tenere un
certo meraviglioso nel posto più grande
che abbiamo che conta 3mila posti è
stato un concerto indimenticabile e la
mia vita da quel giorno in poi è stata
completamente stravolta tutto il mondo
ha parlato di rocchi mille quindi la cnn
end di sì la bbc al jazeera le monde el
pais tutti volevano sapere quello che
avevamo combinato ed è stato davvero
un'avventura incredibile ma il problema
che si è posto quando abbiamo raggiunto
l'apice del successo è questo
e adesso cosa facciamo abbiamo
realizzato il nostro sogno più grande
adesso cosa combiniamo sia solamente una
cosa che potevamo fare
in quel momento perché tutti ci dicevano
adesso invitate gli 2 invitate le docce
di cartasi veritate bruce springsteen
però non potevamo fare da rifare la
stessa cosa perché ovviamente non
avrebbe avuto lo stesso impatto l'unica
cosa che potevamo fare era cambiare ora
cambiare idea a cambiare sogna quando si
è all'apice del successo
psicologicamente è abbastanza complicata
immaginate che ne so buffon dopo aver
vinto il mondiale al 2016 deciso che era
ping pong
ma questo invece è esattamente quello
che abbiamo quello che abbiamo fatto
abbiamo cominciato a guardarci dentro ci
siamo resi conto che noi non eravamo
solamente un tributo una grande band noi
stessi eravamo una grande band e quindi
ci siamo definiti la più grande rock
band del mondo perché almeno in termini
numerici posso dire che che lo siamo
cosa fanno le grandi band le grandi band
fanno concerti fanno dischi fanno
videoclip fanno partecipazioni e quindi
il sogno successivo è stato quello di
creare realizzare un grandissimo
concerto in uno stadio in cui 1.200
persone provenienti da tutto il mondo
avrebbero dovuto cantare una set list di
diciotto canzoni dal vivo davanti a
tante persone
anche lì di nuovo abbiamo ricominciato a
lavorare come dei matti per trovare i
soldi per trovare i musicisti per capire
come fare suonare dal vivo davanti a
così tante persone e dopo un anno allo
stadio dino manuzzi di cesena 15 mila
persone hanno assistito ad uno
spettacolo mai visto prima in cui i 1200
persone hanno effettivamente suonato e
dato un grande spettacolo quindi secondo
sogno realizzato kabul
ovviamente realizzato questo sogno ci
siamo posti di nuovo un altro per me
adesso cosa cavolo combiniamo in realtà
mentre stavamo osservando tutto questo
abbiamo cominciato a realizzare
e mentre guardavamo tutti i musicisti
che suonavano ci siamo resi conto che
quello che stavamo mettendo in piedi è
un qualche cosa che andava al di là di
un grande spettacolo
stavamo rappresentando un grande valore
questo grande valore è legato allo
spirito dello stare insieme lo spirito
della storia insieme significa che tante
persone anche musicisti comuni sono in
grado se vanno tutti nella stessa
direzione sono ben organizzati sono in
grado di dare un enorme spettacolo molto
più grande di quello che i singoli
individui riuscirebbero a realizzare gli
stessi che sono per noi sostanzialmente
sono negli scantinati in un pub per due
soldi
abbiamo dei cantanti che cantano sotto
la doccia piuttosto che al karaoke e
tutti ciascuno di loro quando è iniziato
quando lo fa quando canta sotto la
doccia sogna di suonare davanti a una
platea sterminata di persone davanti a
migliaia di persone come le grandi
rockstar ma questo è un sogno che loro
non potranno mai realizzare
individualmente quello che stiamo
cercando di fare è fargli realizzare
questo sogno collettivamente quindi in
modo da condividere tutti insieme allo
stesso obiettivo si riesce a raggiungere
qualcosa di davvero straordinario che si
ci pensiamo
è un valore e un qualcosa che va ben al
di là della musica una cosa che può
essere applicata praticamente in tutti
gli ambiti in tutti gli ambiti sociali e
quindi il nostro sogno si è trasformato
quasi naturalmente nel desiderio di
portare avanti questo valore in giro per
il mondo e quindi reclutare migliaia e
migliaia di musicisti in ogni angolo del
pianeta far vivere loro un'esperienza
incredibile e far capire far toccare con
mano alle persone che le persone comuni
riescono a fare davvero delle grandi
cose
bene ora finito questo questa questa
breve storia personale
ho cercato e mi sono divertito nel
concepire un grafico che vuole di
scrivere un po l'approccio ai sogni bene
la processione si può dividere secondo
il mio punto di vista secondo due
direzioni due direttive principali
una è quella dell'ambizione e l'altra è
quella della pianificazione con
un'ambizione che va da 0 6 siamo
nell'ambito del cinismo barra
l'assegnazione fino all'ambito del
cosiddetto realismo tra 6 e 8 parliamo
di sogni sopra lotto parliamo di miraggi
con una pianificazione al di sotto del 2
siamo in un ambito della del fatalismo o
di una totale ingenuità
chiunque si pianifichi al di sopra del 7
soffre di un disturbo ossessivo
compulsivo una cosa molto importante è
quella che io chiamo la curva della
serenità che sta sopra la curva della
serenità
credo che non la viva particolarmente
bene perché vuole pianificare troppo
anche quello che non pianificabile che
sta sotto
bene o male ci sta dentro come vedete in
questo grafico quindi si creano alcune
zone che adesso andiamo a riempire
nell'angolo in basso a sinistra ci sono
quelli che vivono alla giornata o chi si
uccide di canne questi li chiamo gli
eletti che vive alla giornata è insomma
chi insegue un sogno ma in realtà non fa
niente per per inseguirlo sono i
sognatori inconcludenti chi insegue dei
miraggi però con ingenuità senza
pianificare sono i bambini oppure che
compra troppi gratta e vinci
io non so se c'è qualcuno che ricompra
io sì ma ogni tanto niente di male
essere bambini insomma chi insegue i
miraggi con un minimo di pianificazione
in più sono gli artisti
poi dopo c'è un'ampia categoria di
persone che crede di riuscire a
inseguire i sogni pianificando e ultra
pianificando e questi sono gli illusi e
infine ci sono quelli che inseguono i
miraggi addirittura inseguire miraggi
credono di poter pianificare che devono
essere completamente pazzi
e poi ci sono una categoria di persone
che non hanno delle ambizioni
particolari però vogliono tra
pianificare la loro vita e questi sono
gli schierati e quindi sono quelli che
fanno che so ammette una sua ex è la
lista della spesa chi apre un mutuo
quarantennale tutti i project manager
loro sono gli schierate c'è qualche
project manager qui ok e affido fosse
una zona intermedia di che chiamiamo la
di confort dove ci sono tante persone e
infine un'area in cui a cui io cerco di
ambire che sono i sognatori responsabile
segnato ai responsabili sono persone che
individuano una un ramo di sogno
raggiungibile sanno benissimo che non è
possibile ultra pianificare per
raggiungere un sogno un sogno si si
insegue non si pianifica quindi uno
potrebbe dire vabbè ma allora non è
possibile avere delle ambizioni da 10 è
possibile avere delle ambizioni da dieci
se questa macro ambizione viene
suddivisa in tante micro ambizioni
quindi coinvolgendo magari tante persone
io voglio vincere le elezioni da solo
non se la potrà mai fare sarebbe un
miraggio
però se io coinvolgo tante persone che
condividono con me lo stesso sogno
questo non diventa più una macro
ambizione da dieci ma magari diventa un
sogno da otto un'altra strada per
inseguire un ambizione da 10 e quella di
dividere un mega sogno in tanti micro
soggettivi e quindi quello che magari
non era possibile
all'inizio di un percorso man mano che
si procede diventa possibile in un
secondo momento e questo è un po quello
che è successo a rocky 1600 avessi
pensato iniziando questo e divertimento
che il mio sogno di lì a poco sarebbe
stato quello di creare una community
globale di musicisti e portare in giro
per il mondo il messaggio dello spirito
dello stare insieme essere stato
completamente pazzo invece magari oggi
dopo 23 anni di lavoro in cui ho
raggiunto e realizzato tanti micro sogni
posso dire che questo non è più un
miraggio ma è un sogno raggiungibile poi
magari non se lo farò mai però non posso
considera non posso considerare questo
un un miraggio dai 10 quindi tenendo
bene in mente questo questo meraviglioso
grafico sperando che vi sia utile
auguro a tutti voi di segnare
responsabilmente
grazie